this is good news for
European citizens who travel your
subscriptions to platforms for
music, films, e-books or
sports broadcasts will no longer be
blocked when you cross the border
the European parliament is working on the
issue
a new law should allow
users to  'having access everywhere in
the union to its cultural or sports content
is a kind of exception to
deport a signal for some time
on the condition of two things that it is
a temporary travel time and
secondly that we can check
that you have paid in your
country of residence
the subscription that you claim to have on a
trip impossible therefore for a person
who lives in sweden to benefit from a
cheaper subscription in belgium
the project does not call into question
the right to  author as it exists
today in each country, the
distribution rights for a film, for example,
will remain attached to a territory  ory
is an annual saving of 5,136
billion euros for all of
the artistic activity of the 28 countries
of europe
we have taken good care that
copyright, in particular the control of
the ip address on  your place of residence
is impassable more than 50% of
europeans use the internet on
mobile devices smartphones
tablets laptops new
reality to which the european union has
decided to adapt